So next kind of coverage I want to talk about is boundary value coverage.
Boundary value coverage unlike some of the other coverage measures to be looked out
doesn't have any specially take technical definition.
Could be use it to me in different things. We're going to look at in a broad sense.
Wihat boundary value coverage basically says is when a program depends on some numerical range
and when the program has different behaviors based on numbers within that range
then we should test numbers close to the boundary.
So let's take the example where we're writing a program to determine
whether somebody who lives in the USA is permitted to drink alcohol.
So we want is the 21 years of age or more is fine for them to drink alcohol
and if they are less than 21 that is to say 20 or less then it is not legal for them to drink alcohol.
We just want to get the boundary value coverage on this program, we want to include the ages of
20 and 21 in our test input and possibly also to 19 and 22 simply close enough to the boundary values
that there maybe interesting behaviors looking good as well.
The insight here is that one of the most prominent kinds of errors that we made while
creating software is off by one error.
Off by one error can almost always be triggered by a value with
the boundary and so that's what we're trying to do here.
What I've done here is frame the boundary value coverage as a function of only one variable
and also I've framed it in terms of the program specification not in terms of the implementation.
So let's look at those two issue and term. So let's consider a program with two inputs.
It's assume for the sake of arguments that these inputs are treated independently
by the software that we are running.
So the first input is going to be the age of your car and where insurance company here
and we're going to decline to insure cars more than 20 years old.
The other parameter is the age of the driver and here we're going to decline
to insure drivers who are less than 18 years old.
If the software treats this values independently will probably okay testing values around 18
independently of the age of the car and testing car ages around
20 years old independently of the age of the driver.
Now on the other hand, if we had specific knowledge of our implementation
consider these variables together then we probably also need to test this combinations of inputs
put in the other boundaries and you could see the problem here is that of course
as the number of inputs of the program goes up the number of test cases
can grow very large because we have to consider the interaction between all
possible combinations of variables that are dependent.
On the other hand, if our variables are independent then we can test this separately.
So that was briefly to visit the issue of whether we are doing boundary value coverage
with respect to the requirements of this specification purpose of software or whether we are doing it
with respect to the implementation.
Let's go and revisit the program we have a little bit earlier where I inserted a bug into our stats function
which causes it to misbehave for some inputs and not for others.
So if you recall, we have the function here stats which computes the minimum, the maximum,
median, and the mode of the list of numbers and the problem I post you in a quiz was
to break this function in such a way that
a collection of test cases getting good coverage on it wouldn't discover the bug.
And so the way I accomplished this was by taking the absolute value of the inputs
and so here is a bug, what we're going to do is it's only going to be discoverable when
we pass numbers into the function which contain negative values.
So if we think about what it takes to get boundary value coverage on a function like this
and now we're talking about rounded boundary value coverage considering the implementation
not just the specification what will happen is a function like absolute value
would change its behavior around zero and so what we need to do get boundary value coverage
of the absolute value function is call it with a negative argument and a positive argument.
So to get good boundary value coverage on this function, we would have been forced to call it
with a list containing at least one negative number and we most likely
in that case would have discover the bug.
Let's look at this function in its broader context. We have a lot of code here.
For example, i is less than mean, i is greater than max.
We have a lot of different operators in here but I'll have different behaviors around certain boundaries
and so to get good boundary value coverage on this function over all
would be probably extremely difficult.
I don't know a good tools automating this on Python and there are techniques
such as mutation testing that can automate boundary value coverage
at least in some forms in general.